[Music]
polar bears are such icons of the arctic
it's hard for anything else to escape
their shadow
but what if i told you
only a few inches from the ground
there's a host of less celebrated little
creatures who've made a playground of
these brutal conditions and defied all
our expectations i'm not cute i'm a
killing machine not useless pillar of
the ecosystem
not adorable master of camouflage
exactly
hang on tight
because these unsung heroes of the
arctic are going to blow your mind
big time
[Music]
at first glance the arctic feels
brutally devoid of life
though a select group of animals have
figured out a way to thrive
but the real force here works quietly
underfoot
every winter sea ice starts small and
delicate then it grows over millions of
square miles how is it possible that
this freezer holds the key to our entire
planet
like a lung sea ice breathes life into
the arctic every year in a cycle that
impacts the climate across the globe
this is the story from the edge of the
canadian arctic where it all starts
my name's bertie gregory and i'm a
national geographic wildlife filmmaker
everything is at stake
we're all waiting for the big freeze
it's the height of winter on the edge of
the arctic
the landscape is now dominated by ice
[Music]
for the next few months
only the hardiest survive
oh my eyelids keep freezing sharp
you'd think that
the animals that were hardest to film
would be
the polar bears you know the great
wanderers
but really is it's these small animals
that proving the most difficult
come on where are you little guys
you've got to be so careful
not to breathe out on your binoculars
like i've just done because now they're
frozen and i can't see anything through
them
[Music]
oh wow
though basically the size of a domestic
cat
don't let appearances fool you
you see these arctic fox bouncing about
little bundles of fluff with their
little smiley faces it's so easy to
forget that they are in fact little
killing machines
right now they're looking for lemmings a
small little brown rodent which are
hidden in their underground layers under
the snow and the fox is using its
incredible sense of hearing to basically
listen for the little footsteps of the
lambing as it moves about under the snow
and then when they found a lemming under
the snow
well they then have a pretty
extraordinary hunting strategy
[Music]
we've totally found
an arctic fox highway you see in front
of us there's practically more tracks
than there is snow and that's because as
long as the weather's good it'll just
keep on hunting and then place the
leftovers in little underground meat
lockers
these foxes don't mess around
some of them have been recorded making
as many as 90 kills in a single day
ah here we go right
we know that somewhere
on this frozen little pond there's an
arctic hair and the reason that i know
that is the card
these are so fresh you can see how
crispy the edges are with this wind they
would have blown out and be all rough by
now
so that's really cool we just got to
find it
they are the kings of camouflage
i have walked past this spot
four times five times
and i can't believe i didn't notice it
see right at the base
of that big rock
all these arctic hairs
are not stupid
sat in behind this rock right out of the
wind and it's about minus 30 degrees
celsius so
i don't have full control of my
nose lips
or eyebrows
and you also see that every time it
lifts its head to check for predators
it's not turning its head it's not
looking around and that's because its
eyes can see together 360 degrees in all
directions so it doesn't need to look
around it can just head up
okay coast is clear
carry on
man they're quick
they're one of the fastest animals in
the arctic they can clock 37 miles an
hour at top speed
[Music]
with so little to hide behind who
wouldn't want to be fast in the arctic
well
this guy
the snowy owl gave up speed in favor of
a mightier secret weapon
silence
the velvety texture of its feathers and
their comb-like hedges absorb all the
sound they produce
go ahead run
[Music]
you won't even know what got you
[Music]
no way
oh it's eating it
oh it's not no no time for chewing just
swallowing it whole
definitely not a good day for this
lemming
yet many predators rely so heavily on
them that a bad year in the lemming
population turns into a devastating
ripple effect across the arctic
well this blizzards just picked up
and up ahead there's this
group of little brown birds and i want
to know why
anything is flying around in this
the arctic's brutal weather wards off
almost every bird on the planet except
for a few determined little characters
snow buntings are an ice age bird known
for singing their little hearts out
whenever the temperatures start to fall
well below zero
and then there's what seems to be a snow
chicken but these willow tarmigan are no
amateurs in the autumn they grow a solid
clump of rigid feathers over their toes
creating their very own little snowshoes
see these little
little town again just scuttling back
and forth i think i can see little
berries kind of buried under the snow
over there red fox red balls what
the grasshoppers
where you sure it's all right yeah the
grass on the left side got it got it got
it in recent years the red fox has
started invading the arctic
they're so much bigger
they don't just want to claim their new
territory
oh the artifacts
they want to hunt down their competition
[Music]
that arctic fox is not hanging around
it is gone
i mean that presence over red foxes
wow big problem for those arctics
the red's much bigger and
it just totally out completes the
arctics
and that's really a
symbol of the warming climate here
it's allowing the range of the red fox
to push further north into the arctics
[Music]
winter is tough as it is
food gets scarcer
days get shorter and further north the
sun disappears for months
but our unsung heroes are undaunted they
will dig
peck fly or scavenge through the
night and for the sun
its solar winds magically find their way
through as millions of charged particles
strike the earth's atmosphere
[Music]
this place is out of this world
[Music]
[Music]
you